wake up java the bow don't sweat now
feel swell
he does it's a beautiful day you're
gonna burn my truck I'm going
I'm a wall
Oh
hey wastelanders welcome to episode 2 of
games wats paul i show i'm your host
dave joined today by tamoor hussain say
hello hello I was a creepy hello that
was hello don't make it worse hello
doing it was well we playing today we
are playing the first Everest ever
follow gam or fallout the fallout gam
yeah because this is a fallout show it
is 100-percent the title give it away
been reliably informed this is the
fallout by me the only fallout show in
fact this episode 2 of the 4 iphone is
episode 1 was dope it was dope I watched
it more but we mentioned in the first
episode that we're going to be going
into detail on all the games separately
but if you want a vast overview of the
fallout timeline make sure you go watch
episode 1 it was a corker if I do say so
I will say I'm gonna put put this out
there sweetest fallout graphics motion
graphics I have seen there maybe ever
they were pretty sexy they are beautiful
but in the end of the first episode we
asked for your character ideas to play
through each game with and we had some
weird we'd have some great suggestions
we had some corn did you see em who
commented on the video on YouTube no mr.
Matty pies he did he's a heater some
great fall out content himself yeah he
sounds like the kind of guy who spent a
lot of time writing fanfic yeah the
character he suggested was well fleshed
out let's say is that a pun was that
positivity kind of thing yeah well is it
was very brief you should give make a
character named Mattie that's fine I'm
my middle names matthew no really i
don't know because if you carry on going
into it it seemed like Matty's objective
was to place himself and the central of
it that's fine that's what i do we'll
open our pjs and they says give them
orange hair orange hairs fine make him
murder everyone well that's a video game
I'm worried about your Nana's an RPG I'm
genuinely worried about yeah it's in a
real this is a reflection of real what
night but then I would be knocking on
him so hard the last point he makes is
he wants to give the character a giant
dog I'm not sure that's the thing you
can do there's not a slider for that
I bet you there is just but I'm not
money I'm not downloading them on the
problem you have into that party
internet genuinely like it'll become an
encumbrance in nuclear if you've got a
giant dong it's gonna be right way to
San one of my one of my favorite ones
was the common that squiggly man left
here on youtube name him rad ray right
now rod ray bradbury sounds like a rad
dude rides a skateboard he said well he
says he always enjoyed the idea of
leaving the valle to see the radiated
wasteland because you assume that the
rad in radiation meant it was totally
rare backwards hat skateboard not listen
to his paranoia yo tricks yeah collects
all the yugioh cards plays harmonica
it's not that rad and like a blues
musician well I wasted a year of my life
took you that long to learn harmonica it
did I was mostly breathing in and out
like Darth Vader for most of it
beautiful well it goes on to say
actually before saying goodbye to his
tightwad friends and family so long
suckers you tightwads it dawns on him
that is noon that his new name to
signify his new life in the rad land
only to find that war war never changes
and that scorpions are bigger than
people was gnarly man I like that
character yeah imagine imagine just like
your typical like surfer dude just like
leaving a [__] me like it's radon's like
oh in the modern day if you a hipster
wouldn't it how far do you reckon
hipster would make it in the waistband
nothing's anything under whereas a
certain did I think so for the honda yes
it did not only fall into a hole his
grave is literally they're here in lex
on the game's our website makes a very
good point you would love to see a fall
i pray for light playthrough for a very
unintelligent character that's the thing
yeah and doing we will definitely be
doing that in the series of Let's Plays
because if your intelligence is super
low in the game's your dialogue options
are like limited to grunts and
Neanderthal appraises captain Doug yeah
you are pretty much just an idiot
bumbling around the waistline ya know
was that yeah move seems like you
practice that yeah that was a lot of my
childhood hopefully it maybe in like
fallout 3 will do like a low
intelligence playthrough because they
are usually a lot of fun the dialogue
options crack me up yeah we've got
another one another good point from mega
mas 1984 on the site they says I'm the
one of the bastards that killed mr.
house the way interacted with me made me
think he had something to hide and I
read a bit more about him and he felt
really bad i'm talking about Gregory
House it Gregory not probably the show
house mr. house we're talking about a
new big boss called mr. house just to
have Robert house he's an important dude
apparently he is a very important dude
in the fallout law he actually we're not
gonna go into too much detail for house
we're gonna save that for the new vegas
episode but he basically saved New Vegas
but on him does that Layton new Vegas
pretty much all of its still there but
that's hit that's because of him and his
advanced intelligence and wealth well
done mr. house good work social for
diagnosing all those lucas problems well
again to a different house oh he also
goes on to say the one thing I don't
understand about the story in the
fallout universe they perfected and used
atomic energy far better than we did
never advanced much of transistors hence
all the vacuum tubes etc man think it's
not deeply nerdy stuff but it's not
explained it's very good point actually
it's not explained in the law why that
happens but if you compare it to our
real world when the wars ended we kind
of focused on making computers more
efficient smaller more usable more
user-friendly where war never really
stopped in the fallout universe so their
objective they just needed something
that worked didn't matter how it just
needs to get the job done they just
wanted to it didn't have as big or bulky
they just used what they had to like
defend themselves on the communist
threat in China so word of advice for
mega moss if you're ever on the date
never repeat
that free unless it's with me no series
of words about you know happy well until
that transistors do not save that's my
talk don't eat doesn't speak Dondre he
hasn't it hasn't been on a date in 26
years to listen to
but the character that we are going for
today bur NT delivers need is over NT he
he grew i wrote a giant biography for
this guy he's an also a fanfic maestro
yeah it was very well done yep so so
much know so much I had to read it in
two parts but he create kind of created
like you said a Gregory House style
character yeah but we're going to jump
into the game now we're gonna discuss
his character and make it and start our
journey into the wasteland what is his
character's name his name is Frederick
that is a nice name it's a nice name so
it's a suitable name it's kind of like a
low-level villain name yeah it is like
goons sidekick yeah name so let's go
make Frederic let's do it let's do it
Frederick your boy Frederick I don't
know you got in the mount think you like
it looks like that Frederick you got
remember he's a small that that's a
Frederick Frederick face that is it if
you know anyone with that face his name
is Fred his name is probably Frederick
and you shouldn't trust them all that
much so she would talk about the
character that M ver antes created for
us huh so I'll do his stats and all his
books and everything but he actually put
a lot of work into the bio girl was
there was like three paragraphs he says
he likes helping people but it's not a
selfless act no like he's a bit
two-faced we all know someone to face so
Frederick so it's classic French class
is Frederick and he thinks he's the
smartest person in the room he always
thought he was better than those other
fault dwellers from having flashbacks to
my friend from childhood against his
name Frederick oh that's so angry rejig
not built for combat cuz he's got his
smarts yeah it's gonna get bikes Wiley
and intelligent but he likes to engage
in combat as a thing he's not built for
combat but he won't necessarily run away
from Kenobi's that means he's got to use
he's a user yeah
he's gonna keep Frederick he makes
friends that is like kind of a sneaky
name is it the name Frederick reminds me
of like like being the sidekick to a
Disney villain yeah from nairo my dear
Frederick entertainer I don't know idea
I think that's a real person you should
make ratio but see look it says here he
has to get something out of the
relationship yeah so every relationship
he makes he's got to get something out
of it needs to do nothing yeah nothing
it there's no selfless act known he
won't just be friends with you because
you're a cool dude no no she's got it
he's got to get something out of it
either an item or security yeah because
I found see if we if we had Maggie whom
was made by mighty plays he's the kind
of person that will be friends man you
know excuse me it says murder everyone
oh wait now I'm thinking about rad ray
rapidly right ray would be everyone's
friend because rageous Lee wants that he
wants to surround himself with equally
rad people exactly so he would be
friends with you ok so the character he
actually kind of relates it to his a
house md style character he just
diagnosis lupus in everyone yeah replace
his blood bleach yeah walks with a cane
gets really angry at all my tips so he's
not the nicest guy in the wastes but by
no means is either nastiest well it's
not someone you're gonna invite around
for a nice friendly iguana on a stick no
definitely not so could you give me his
traits and tags so what we start with s
but I've got the oh my god the stats ok
great so his traits are small frame
small frame thin dude yep not quite as
big as other vault dwellers but that
never slowed you down you can't carry as
much be your more agile finesse finesse
your attack show a lot of finesse you
don't do as much damage we caused more
critical hits his tags are repair repair
so cookie fixins love smart dude what
else we got science science because he's
a nerd good nude and of course dr. Don
assembly style Frederick is a man a
person who as a child I can only assume
was repeatedly wedgie over and over
again that's but maybe that's why I
which has which which is what informs
his current personality yeah okay so
this is the overseer that is an insane
beard to face ratio or here to face
ratio it really is he's like his
eyebrows on mustaches like little
caterpillars on his face you're you're
more concerned with his caterpillar
eyebrows rather than the water chippy
sending don't care about I never trust
someone with that that prominent
eyebrows for mine yawns are low prom and
look at that it's like they're trying to
escape he does look like it's like let's
try to kiss we belong on your head of
course you would the thing is he
actually he says you're the only hope we
have but he's actually sent someone else
out all ready for you yeah what I'm
sneaky dude I'm gonna swear but the guy
the guy actually ends up in a vat of
forced evolutionary virus by the stuff
that actually creates super mutants and
it becomes all Google ified and gross oh
wow do you find that going here yeah way
way into the games we might actually get
to that point but we do I have an
objective for this playthrough though
yes we're gonna far viciously we're not
gonna play the entire thing no cuz it's
a long game it's long and a lot of it
can be quite boring to watch yeah just
wandering through san yeah like hexagon
by hexagon that's true shuffling along
and then getting ganked by scorpions
yeah no one likes think we have to set
yourself an objective and that objective
is to find dogmeat dog me the original
Oh Jane dog me onion that's what we
gonna do first we gotta actually get out
of this dope-ass vault mm-hmm vol 13
right so okay so not only I mentioned
the other person they said that does not
look like fallout 3 this because it's
follow one damn that is drastically
different so people who who may have
played fallout 3 and then thought I'm
gonna go back to the original ones
because allure DS games they they're
usually in for a rude awakening like I
am this could really run on a modern
phone so this is the outside of vault 13
bought for in
the votes are like you explain it in the
first episode with the law yeah they
each how each have a purpose right yeah
they each have a kind of social
experiment connected to them well most
of them the thing with the vault 13 is
is it was actually it was kind of a
cross between an experiment in isolation
it's meant to station up for 200 years
but it was also means that it could be
used as a control group so whilst they
were having is in every scientific
experiment need a control group if the
scientists of the enclave survived you
could then compare it to your other
findings the other ones but because of
the broken water and they had to open
their doors and super send Frederick out
Frederick out yeah so Frederick wait the
other guy they send someone else at
right yeah obviously the overseers sense
obviously is already unreliable narrator
but Frederick is the hero of the day
Frederick is yeah but the thing is if
they were meant to have a surplus of
water chips because they were going to
stay shut for so long so they needed
lots of water but the water chips
actually ended up involved aight due to
a shipping like a shipping error amazon
sent my package to the wrong house but i
believe that to me all the time do you
know how many warships I've lost because
ramsden so to actually go to get a
warship first place me to go to his
vault 15 where's this map all about this
is basically how you travel the
wasteland right so you find these
settlements here like vol.13 and you
click on the map and that's where you go
you can get random encounters on this
map right like radroaches was pop up and
be like what's up all right so unlike
unlike modern fallouts where you are
given the entire world and for example
traveling from one point to here it's
just you watching this kind of red line
yeah in modern fallouts is like you
actually have to run that entire thing
so this is more like a bunch of isolated
locations young together by random
encounters and stuff like that but they
did actually think about like the towns
and stuff because this is this is shady
sands right it's it's a surely looking
place so nice shady it's actually quite
a nice place but with a nail down
whoever named it in no favors that's
true but the thing is you can't go in
there your weapons drawn because they
will know is that the same in new vegas
and pull out three people talk to you
differently and they like can you put
your weapon away please but these guys
will literally just pop a cap in your
ass all right as you walk through the
game that's cuz how they roll in shady
sands that's that good shake the
shadiest of places like the shady
quarter has been met any more people
looking shady and they take a mile you
noticed it was on the way it was between
vault 13 or 15 that's because shady
sands was founded by some of the members
from vault 15 volt 15 opened after 50
years so this is between 14 and 15 it's
only yeah they thought were there 15 s
there and shady sands right in the
middle this shouldn't have befallen them
though this isn't a vault okay this is
just a village right there is revolver
women yeah somewhere somewhere okay but
shady sands was founded by some of the
people from vol.15 about 15 opened after
50 years and their experiment was that
they had people from very diverse
ideologies and they kind of it was an
experiment see if they'd separate
themselves naturally which they did
because a court of the people made shady
sounds and then another quarter made the
Raiders the Vipers another quarter made
the Raiders the Jackals and another
quarter made the Raiders the great vault
is incredibly important then yeah
basically that all the factions were
born there pretty much like you see the
Great Khans in New Vegas and that's like
the other side of America that was when
the Great Khans did their great
immigration and built up their own town
so gonna talk about rad scorpions that's
Guardians fun fact my cousins are known
as the Great Khans back in Pakistan
really yeah no I made that up as well I
need to stop trusting you sorry so this
guy this guy's Seth surfs looks sets the
pretty legit guy he's like the head
guard but they've got problems oh we did
want to go to the razz grew up in caves
yet no but another thing about the shady
sands did you play new vegas i do anyway
and obviously the NCR play a big part
they do this is where the NCI were born
oh wow this is the first sovereign
states of people who don't know what the
NCR our new california republic then one
of the major functions in the west coast
but um yeah the guy we're gonna go talk
to you now is actually the first
president the NCR and Seth remember the
ranges from New Vegas you guys the
really cool helmets and body armor he
was the very first NCI Ranger and his
face is actually on the twenty-dollar
bill chef sad face wow man that sounds
like the hero of this story Seth done
thump very well from south he's all
right we're gonna go sierra de she's the
creepy dude in the robes well greeting
Oh shady sands might be our nation needs
to catch some Z's my business in shady
sands is for you to get out of my face
damn high okay I throw this is the first
president of the NCR it looks like you
might be party guana okay its eyes well
it is the desert you know what else is
gonna okay so he wants to know why he
doesn't trust new people so what would
what would Frederick's so high i'm
saving entire people from destruction
that's pretty Frederick things wait now
Frederick okay let's go for these I'm
from a small village west of here I'm
just exploring and I mean you know home
that that's kind of deceptive well
depends if we meet him arm yeah no but
Frederick would act like act like he
doesn't mean anyone home when actually
in his mind he's just constant murder
cycling through my Frederick might just
be like mind your own God what suits you
my reasons are mine to keep I'm from a
vault to the way member Frederick
Frederick thinks he's better than
everyone in the vault so he's gonna save
them all destruction he's their hero
good point ok I don't have to tell you
anything I believe oh oh he's not
there's no pausing me did you get kicked
up kicks me out damn can you come
straight back in don't worry about me
sir that's all right so that's like I
mean O'Hara dare she's a bit yeah a bit
overzealous Tyra desh gonna go talk to
you Ian now it's called here he is hello
Ian so in keeping with our character
where we gonna recruit someone to
actually give us a hand now that is
typical Frederick yeah classic Fredrik
classic Fredrik mean get someone to the
leeward who do the dirty work for you so
I'm Fredrik what do you do here so Ian
he was um it says he I was a guard for
the merchants of the hub do you know
crimson caravan some of there's
something else that was referencing
right yeah he was a crimson caravan
guard and he got shot by Raiders so now
he he was saved by the people of shady
sands and he kind of 0 is the Milwaukee
life debt so he's just hanging around
and like
helping them out as like they saved his
life sweeping the floor and yay visits
herb and junk town to do some training
where's a sorry to hear about your
injury could you help me out a bit see
straight to the point that's Frederick I
don't care about your life story I need
your help fending off her since this
place it's boring tell you what standard
rates 100 caps now we could pay him or
we could deceive and be like you know
you look like the kind of guy who likes
a bit of action thanks bit of violence
look it's cold exactly he likes action
so just give him a piece of the action
maybe like we say we'll give him a share
of the loot yeah if you live that long
man right that is how Frederick doesn't
exactly so we gotta actually go
companion now I know he's going to do
all our dirty work for us Frederick is
the Iago of this game and I yeah i'm not
talking about like Shakespeare new yoga
give my lad Harriet from the leg yeah I
know that culture it's it says a lot
where my brain in C went yeah the parent
for the paranoid not Shakespeare not now
not beautiful literature now man that
parrot that was voice I what was his
name God for after one Gilbert Godfrey
does not voice anything to fall out
unfortunately yeah unfortunate that
would be a whole new never know I mean
fallout 4 is not out yet I know I've
been blocked into this corner haha I'm
not even kidding Liam wins and he's like
you thought you as my he's gonna get me
killed aya look what's the left of me
it's a bow y Wi-Fi this is right now
Frederick is having flashbacks to be
shoved into a locker in a little kid I
need you to change information you move
along race each package Ian I'm a Hawaii
is we got out of that only moments from
giving you a wedgie like cooling your
underpants over your head I didn't even
see if the rope was here there is Steve
all 15 yrs like a whole of the ground
only very small vault Arthur as a whole
it expands it wasn't like naughty little
there yeah ok it wasn't a thousand
people living in the tin shed we've got
to get our way through
it's now rats are fine as long as
they're not giant scorpions well that's
that it's it's the typical RPG thing
isn't it that's the first thing you need
to fight in an RPG rat rats DM the mall
rats were actually some well he's not
won the the american government invented
so when they were at their with their
war in China and they created a species
that would be very invasive so like how
that are they used to like you already
had the FBI for that why don't they need
no I feel like if they put loads of mole
rats into China they were like eating
all the supplies and undermining the war
effort that's what that was their idea
and they had even had a kill switch like
in their evolution so like to sonic t
turn off all the mall rats yeah
basically I'm not sure how they would do
that but that was their idea is there
one question where you find the kill
switch and turn off all the mall rats no
because that would that would make like
a lot of things easier we're getting
through our loop right as we got none of
the rope and we got the most rad what is
that lacking that look cool this is a
new getup that looks like insurers
jacket from fist of the north star it's
actually a reference to Mad Max is a Mad
Max is Jackie I think you'll find that
Kent Road jacket this is elise mcmahon
max Mad Max kenshiro mad Max's jacket
this gate this whole game is inspired by
Mad Max wasteland all that stuff and dog
meat we'll get to him later be he's also
inspired by Mad Max suddenly I put the
Mad Max ameron and I'm landing big spear
thrusts like it's nobody business oh my
oldest it's the less than alright that's
the great mall rat like a great amaura
and he missed twice it's not great start
for the grim all right imagine seen
their like you got the ambush and then
you failed I am the best mole rat I am
great ah if the letter Mora had seen
that he would have probably felt better
about himself and been like a mediocre
Maura well to see is like she also has a
great amaura I could fail that hard
maybe I'm not so bad the great mulroy
did fail real hard he is dead so it we
need to just go over here and see if
there's a water chip is that that was
like I said the reason we came here and
then you return it and game over well
you'd think but because um vault fifth
vol.15 opened
50 years hmm and like like I said
someone when shady sands some of them
raiders went and did Rader II things
like the vault has just been picked
clean of all of its resources they left
this dope leather jacket though that yep
so they weren't that good at their job
but it does mean there ain't no water
[__] for you son it's a body I would not
put that in my explosive consisting of
nitroglycerin mixed with an absorbent
substance just gonna put that in my
circular next to the bullets the syringe
the medi-pack that pliers and long
enough a farm next to the flare yeah so
stuff that can puncture it and ignite it
yeah it also took some grenades it's
like it's no big deal oh and we've got
machine gun ho ho ho I've got a machine
gun that that was a good reference it's
not animate don't care that's die hard
if you don't care about die hard we need
to re-evaluate our friendship what I
said that's um good luck daughter's
booking it yeah there is yeah sometimes
a helluva ways to yonk dome you better
keep that way jug town as a friendly
place put your stuff away yeah it's go
psycho gonna and I check yourself don't
tell me what to do with a loser boy that
is again a very Frederick like he's so
so much of a loser I'm also scared
they'll mob movies I think loser boy I
think Frederick is also smart enough
does not say lose a boy to an armed
guard with all of his friends behind him
but he's also the kind of person that
would react when questioned yeah because
he thinks he's smarter than everyone
else so who is this guy to tell him what
to do I'm just gonna be like okay sorry
sure for the sake of progressing in his
quest for a record yeah and he's he can
see like ten steps ahead so he knows
like this isn't the fight to take like
let this or just watch over you a
greater greater a block plot right write
him down in your book as someone you
need to murder later yeah I'll be back
for you whatever your name is and you
see what is no human male human male oh
no his name's cowl more okay hip out he
comes from space
so this is young town but we're here
lives up to his name yeah we don't we're
not going to explore junk town we're
just going to come and complete our
quest the funny thing is right here's
dogmeat just there we can see him is him
just it just listed as a dog but it's
dogmeat if you talk to the because he's
trapped someone in his house maybe
talked to him he says talk to a dog meat
if you talk to the guy who's trapped he
recognizes us because we're wearing this
Jackie runs right to us if we weren't
marrying this jacket you have to give
him an iguana a stick like be his friend
but because we're wearing this jacket he
thinks we're his owner way thinks York
enteral he thinks with bad max the guy
when we wait if we talked to Phil yeah
Phil's in here hi Phil all right Phil
what's going on for wouldn't trust that
bit thing if I were you to kill her yeah
well ok what you think Phil punch phones
god what talk to me then I think you
have to talk to him at daytime but he
says um he actually says like a whole
reference to Mad Max if you ask him
described as only says the guy was tall
dark haired graying around the edges
dressed all in black leather Lorelai
leather and like that's a good idea in
the desert and he carried a shotgun
which in road road road warrior run a
road warrior he carries a sawed-off in
his hip doesn't and hangs out dog meat
nice Adventures of Frederick close are
they we found dogma oh yeah I objective
was to unlock the MX's dog yeah and that
was the objection is ourselves so we've
got a partner that we can rely late
we've got a blindly loyal Glenn limo
that's Frederick is pretty please
himself he's pretty set for himself now
we didn't hear what the vault we can
just assume that he goes on to how does
this we're not gonna pick it again are
we know we have another good swing so
the end game of fallout mm-hmm if you're
playing it not Frederick yep so you have
you find a water chip in necropolis you
take in a topless it sounds like zambito
yeah basically what it's where all the
ghouls live it is very irradiated you
take it back to the vault lovats the OPC
is like wow check out my beard has grown
while you were gone join now now can
to my chest hair but then you find out
about the super mutant menace and the
master and the Masters just a big anthro
morphic blob that's falling too many
viruses and he he's four he better I
keep falling in virus he got stuck in a
vat of for Stephen Lucian we've iris
right and he was just stop this is the
dude that originally got sent out from
the vault no that's not the same dude
okay cuz but yeah you can meet him in a
later city okay but then you have to
save the vault from the supermutants
directly attack your vault if you if
you're not fast enough yeah oh wow so
you have to save their safe garden from
super mutants and then if you do all
that if you save the vault twice both
with water and security guess what
happens to the vault dweller he get made
lord and master of all he gets banished
because the vault the axiom that is a
the oversea is so paranoid he thinks
because you have such experience in the
outside world now he doesn't he doesn't
trust the influence you would hold over
the other dwellers so he just sends you
off typical in it he sends off he goes
off and he founds at his own village and
that village is where we will sell out
heaven it smell geert am sorry that
religious where we will start our next
adventure the village of arroyo so this
is what is full RT so this is the end of
Frederick's adventure thank you again I
personally hold Frederick dies a
horrible death on his way to a bit of a
jerk he is an absolute joke but thank
you randy ver NT for creating the
character stuff I hope you're not
actually like him in your life hope we
will then you will get in touch and try
and hook you up with some cool fallout
swag so now comes the part of the show
where we check out your stuff stuff
create by the community you might have
noticed that two more has changed whoa
magic everybody meet kate's in your
first video know that yeah well not ever
not ever know just for the first game
suavity facility with me
in the magical world of Fallout sound
more excited King I'm sorry right we're
going to look at some radical community
stuff radical kids like radiation rats
exactly you're ganna you get em caught
up on the puns already so Bethesda
brought out their first video in the
special series going over the the list
of stats and the special list the same
day brought our last video so we thought
let's check it out this week yes and see
what the people are saying about it the
one takeaway thing I think everyone is
saying if we play this section right now
use anything short sharp or dirty an old
baseball get creative with more than a
Lynette now how many people we were
looking to read it before and the
comments yeah I guess how many people do
you think want the paddleball as a
weapon well I should have counted um
like I saw at least between 50 and 75
comments so there were about 350
comments on that one thread I reckon it
at least a quarter of them we're about
the paddle ball people love the paddle
ball like paddle ball hype adam imagine
if you can make it into a tiny ball and
chain that you somehow yeah dling what i
did see someone getting excited because
you can upgrade your weapons its
compatible as a weapon you'll be able to
upgrade it and it's all those adjectives
like silenced time it's part of a
credible can you imagine quad shot
paddleball scoped paddle ball like
you're sitting on a hill and the rubber
string just guy goes for like a hundred
meters and then fires back at you yeah I
would play that if that like I'm gonna
make a prediction now if that's not in
the game will be modded it'll be one of
the first everythings molded into the
game I'm so excited which is amazing but
they say
is it now this is super cool did you
ever play like the original fallout 1
and 2 nobody what she play a bit well
the the people behind stasis that game
developers behind a game called stasis
have dared they're making their own
isometric game and the big fallout fans
so they thought let's take all the cool
stuff and fallout 4 that we've seen and
imagine it as an isometric game itself
so they made these couple cool things
I've even got skill decks down here
they've put a lot of F into this yeah
super mutants and red rocket interesting
dialogue going on o stranger we have
human meat to trade awkward because that
is a human my guys is burping right into
the face of this Brahmin and like if
you've got two faces you smell that
twice do you think that's actual
scientific fact yes yeah of course yeah
if everyone if you were a two-headed
person and someone burbs are you both
heads would smell it I don't think
that's ever been a thing that people
have thought about but well I'm glad you
were pioneer yeah of science I am
two-headed smells two-headed smells
that's a great name for man and now
moving on to the world of cosplay how
awesome is this yep it's it's amazing I
can't believe the people are you know
taking that kind of blurry stuff later
it's like a four second piece of the
trailer of the bear with a minigun which
is cool because it's a bear with a
minigun and then he's made a whole
cosplay of it not only is he made the
pit boy he's made the whole minigun and
however you got the the bear head i'm
not sure if he just got a costume that
you're lying around and set fire to part
of it i do that for fun anyway that's
super cool there is his cosplay cuz it's
soup just looks like a normal soup
really that he's sort of gone well I'm
never gonna need this again so let's
just mess up if you go on their own
their facebook page hectic design
they've got a load pictures of him in
this and he made
well it's it's battle armor power armor
yeah but it's like NC ask anything he
calls it NCR salvaged by armor well that
looks that looks like the real deal I
feel like I saw him I mean I'm sure
there's plenty of people wearing that
kind of stuff but I definitely saw
someone dressed like that I gamescom
what if it was him I would be their
friend I'm gonna I'm gonna find him and
ask him if he remembers me from that two
seconds I saw him in a corridor and
you'll definitely yes yeah for that look
look at this giant massive cosplay so
we've got here like a giant mound of
vault dwellers which is cool in itself I
think this guy's got a rebar club she's
made a mini new clauncher she's blinked
so kind of gonna ruin that one for the
South's various like different faults
they can't seem to decide on the shade
of blue which one do you think's closest
to the right shade of blue then what
would not this one that's you die I
actually think this one the one that is
like the square-headed vault boy yeah
I'm chance to agree with you yeah that's
just cuz he's the brightest the others
look like they want this this one is too
bright this one's like washed out some
light into that I think I think this is
the shade of blue but then over here
we've got a brotherhood scribe yeah his
robes Brotherhood of Steel powerometer
chat hot it will your form a g1 during
our games coming that an enclave soldier
with the sati pose sancya son clave
soldier ever I mean if you're in the
Enclave you're allowed to be sassy
you've got I bought that is that easy
with a conclave t-shirt I mean it looks
amazing but just it's so I really hope
he just ran around his arms behind him
he's beeping at people threatening right
oh yeah like they got lasers and
everything we've got like an adventure
time vault dweller here yeah that's
certainly something someone's made a
mini nuke up here some got a sniper
rifle some NCR ranges caesar's legion
chaps you have effort these people have
put in is staggering it is a good thing
these with game events let you bring up
anything yeah we I saw that at games
come as well they would like people
walking around that basically looked
like they were just in the army that's
kind of scary I mean if you've got a gun
that looks like again this this looks
like a gun what this guy has that
definitely just looks like a gun but
then they person who's next to them is a
nerf gun so like both ends of the
spectrum existing well now I'm scared to
go to these things it get it get shot
well just don't let them target you in
vats yeah pageant so that's some of the
coolest stuff that I think we've seen in
the past week for coming from the
community but for the next episode we
need your help similar to think we did
this episode we need a character from
you guys to wonder the waist width but
what we're going to do next episode is
going to play all the way from fallout 2
all the way up to Fallout New Vegas and
we're going to see the evolution of the
game you saw the footage earlier today
how is I like top down old-school style
and now fall out for it shoot you shoot
bang Bang's look so pretty so can see
how they've changed from one extreme to
the other but if you've got any fan art
as well we love checking out all the fan
art your pictures your theories anything
fall out related make sure you fire us
you can leave it in the comments section
below or you can go on twitter and use
the hashtag GS Fallout and I will be
monitoring that or tweet me at a regular
Dave or sweet Kate at how not to draw
how not to draw so make sure you tweet
us leave your character suggestions and
make sure you stay tuned for next week's
episode thank you so much for watching
and we will see you next week
mmm